okay we're going to begin with breaking
news out of chat where the armies
announced president idris debbie has
been killed
the army says he was leading soldiers
fighting rebels on the front line
debbie had just won re-election and was
one of africa's longest
serving leaders hibba morgan's joining
us now live from chad's capital in
jama heba what more do we know about
what's been happening
well rob but what we do have right now
is a statement that came from the army
itself which is that
uh president debbie who's been running
the country for more than 30 years
and who was set to lead it for another
five years
passed away from injuries he sustained
over the weekend in the fight between
the government forces
and the rebel group known as the front
for change and concord in the northern
region of cannon
now let's go back to how this all
unfolded on april 11th
on the day of the election uh where
debbie was running for his sixth term
uh the rebels came in from libya where
they have a non-aggression pact with the
uh libyan warlord khalifa after and
launched an attack
on a government station at the border
region of tibesti
and then they went on to advance until
they reached the region of canaan which
is about 300 kilometers
from the capital in germany now the
statement from the army at the time was
that they had launched airstrikes
against the rebel groups to prevent them
from advancing
uh to the region of canada which is
where they were able to reach up until
on saturday
of just this weekend uh the government
then went on to
assure the citizens who were panicking
here in the capital in germany that
everything was okay
and that there was no need to concern
and that the rebels will not reach the
capital
like they had announced and we also know
that uh president debbie himself
went to the front lines along with top
army officials
to uh lead the battles against uh the
group uh and announced later that at
least 300 were killed and more than 140
were captured while the rest fled and
were being pursued by the government
military
now we hadn't heard from debbie uh over
the weekend we didn't hear from him
yesterday as well on the day
that the national electoral commission
announced that he had won the
uh election by nearly 80 percent uh we
we were expecting to hear a statement
from him uh to
uh to to assure his supporters and to
uh basically welcome the results of the
national electoral commission
that now will not be happening we know
that uh we just learned from the army
that he had sustained injuries during
that
battles over the weekend and those were
the reasons and the bad the injuries
were the reasons why he passed away
so he would not be leaving the country
for the next five years
obviously the news is just coming out
and we're trying to assess what's going
on but is there any sense from where you
are
of how the country is going to be
reacting to this
well the capital has been very tense rob
even before the announcement that their
president
has passed away over the past couple of
days with the announcement that the
rebels were advancing towards in germany
lots of stores around the capital were
closed people were mostly staying
indoors because they were concerned
about the security situation
that only increased yesterday morning
when they saw more government troops
patrolling the streets saying that they
were worried that this these are signs
that the government statements
that the rebels have been repelled and
that they were not advancing may not be
correct and that they could be some
threats to their safety so lots of
people opted to stay indoors and lots of
stores opted to remain closed
now last night we heard celebratory
gunfires uh around the capital in
germany despite the army saying that
that should not be the case because of
the panic mode that the people were in
uh but we heard uh celebratory gunfire
nonetheless
around the capital in germany today
things were quite normal in the morning
we've seen stores opening
uh people were out and about they seemed
to be a little bit more assured
after seeing that debbie was poised to
leave for another five years and that
the army has been repelled
as per the government statement we're
yet to see how they will react to this
they were very assured
this morning they were in a panic mode
yesterday evening and yesterday morning
so things have been very fluid here in
the capital in germany
but thanks very much indeed that's
hibber morgan talking to us from chad's
capital in jama i want to bring in
um ami didris whose life for us in abuja
has been covering this region for us for
for many years
um the the western countries have often
seen
idris debbie as really a key ally in the
fight against
armed groups like boko haram for example
and of course
now the front for changing concord in
chat what do you think
is going to be the impact of this news
on the security situation in the region
well basically rob let's start with the
chad itself now
succession battle starts
constitutionally the speaker of
parliament is supposed to take over
if the president is indisposed now
whether or not
that will happen uh it remains to be
seen because this is a country
that is um that has seen a lot of coups
a lot of rebellions uh internally within
its own military
and of course the rebellion in the north
as well now regionally
charges involved in peacekeeping
operations or operations against armed
groups
in the lecture region in central africa
and other parts of
the region as well so chad for many
countries
in the region is an important ally in
the fight against uh
extremist group or armed groups that
have been operating in that region
for example china played a critical role
in displacing boko haram from its
territory last year
after an operation led by the president
himself just like the way he did in the
north
he led a force that dislodged boko haram
fighters and iso
fighters from the lectured region
freeing the territory of chad of these
attackers
and he's been a crucial partner for
nigeria a lot of chinese forces are
currently
are part of the multinational drone task
force working in nigeria working in asia
working in parts of cameroon
as well as other parts of the region to
keep ice swap and boko haram away
this will mean a very very tense
situation for the region
especially countries that are struggling
to deal with these armed groups so
it it's very very critical now whoever
succeeds
um child or mr president idris
debbie uh should quickly address the
issue or the vacuum that may likely
arise in case
in in in the in in the incidence of his
death now
so nigeria for example i know is very
worried
it needs to handle the situation very
very well
currently we've seen an uptick in
violence in the lecture
region bordering child as well as parts
of the northeast of nigeria
apart from nigeria chat nigerian
republic also is dealing
with an optic in violence uh crossing
from mali
into niger from burkina faso and
cameroon also has its own share
of violence in the recent past so this
is a very very tense moment for
all countries in the region that have in
one way or the other relied on child
for collaboration in dealing with armed
groups in the region
we were talking there ahmed about the
the succession process but we're just
seeing on chad tv
that the army is being quoted as saying
that a military council
is going to be handling that transition
now
given the fact that people in chad had
really hoped
that this was going to be the end of a
fairly prolonged political process and a
fairly strenuous one
how do you think that that news is going
to go down
for the politicians it it's a very very
heavy blow to democracy whether or not
president idris debbie was a dictator
whether or not he manipulated the
electoral system
that could spell a very very uh
very very lethal blow to democracy in
that country
these army in a region where
military coups are so prevalent in the
recent past
this could mean that child will have to
wait a long time
for it to return to democracy fully we
suspect that this could take probably
three four years
unless of course there is international
pressure to hand over a democrat to a
democratically elected government or
some form of a transitional
uh civilian administration in the region
but for democracy in charge
that should be or that will be on hold
for many who know
the uh the way things work in that
country but i know we're going to be
coming back to you in the next few hours
as we get more information about what's
going on but for now amit idris
thank you very much indeed i want to
bring in marie roger balor she's the
president of africa international media
group and she's joining us now
from paris thank you very much indeed
for being with us um
what does this news mean for the region
but for chad particularly
well first of all is a shock you know it
is just
after an election where he decided
he's one election overwhelmingly
um and he he seemed to be
not removable because of his life
insurance
we seem to be french the french
support and there are french troops in
in
in chad and these troops have
saved him in the past and
you know he has grown very impressive
uh the electoral campaign was very
violent
and uh just uh i think
some people will in this moment remember
that uh
the idris davies troops and police
uh surrounded the home of an opponent
and killed his mother
so something which was regarded as
doomed as um no good sign for debbie
that he will not get away with it in a
way
that was something very special and
what happens now is what i think of is
that the fact
fact this uh formula they announced
this rebellion group um
was very clever to say immediately two
days ago
while struggling and fighting
in the front of canon that they
will not um
withdraw from the the
politics where that's it they will not
redraw
with from the the tree border
area which means they will continue to
back
backhand to work with the french for
uh security in sale and uh
to just to show that it is debbie is not
the
only possible ally with france this was
vacant
and so this
for the french part is will not be
the death of a juice debbie will not be
a very severe bloom
because of that and um
as a matter of fact he was very weak in
his country
uh the um people were opposing him
broadly even if he says he won election
but he knows and people observing
uh knew that he he has lost part of his
grip
of the country um so that
we will find out exactly how he died
because this is uh is quite strange um
it doesn't look like an accident so we
will find out
later but um i think the first
uh the first reaction here is in france
uh in part of on the part of
those who uh work with chad
is is not very appalled they are not
very much support i think they
they have taken contact already with the
the rebels and uh
let me ask you about some news that
we're just getting out of uh
of chad at the moment where i understand
that i i you may have heard me mention
before that chad tv had been quoting the
army as saying that a
military council was going to be put in
place to handle the transition
we're now hearing the general mohammed
qatar the kaka excuse me
the son of the deceased chadian leader
idris debbie is named as
interim head of state now army digits
were telling
us before our correspondent was saying
that this was the imposition of a
military council
was going to be very concerning for the
people of chad
do you think that given the fact that
this man is idris debbie's
son is going to go some way to alleviate
those concerns
well the the main concern here is
somebody said that before
that the democratic process
will be derailed this is always a danger
we see what is happening in mali
uh it's very difficult very tough to get
the
military to uh hand over
the power back to civilians and they are
struggling with
it we don't know how we've been mali and
now in chat
this opens a very critical
period for what we call democracy
and you'll see that
most rebels are basically
from the large area of idris debbie
they have been very active all those
years
some are very close like his nephew
who turned rebel against him and
there are many many people who are very
close
let's say from the family in in terms of
family relationship
but um
[Music]
nobody will know now what if it will be
sort of a progress for the
for the country but it's just a very
critical and delicate situation mario
elizabeth
we appreciate you joining us and al
jazeera thank you very much indeed
i want to go back to hibba morgan our
correspondent who's joining us now live
from
chad's capital and jama so in the last
few minutes as you probably know heber
we've been hearing
that a military council is going to be
put in place to manage the
transition of power and uh ahmed idris's
son is going to be
in charge of that he's named interim
head of state do you think given your
experience
of the country that this is going to go
some way to
making people feel more comfortable
about than to the transition or
as ahmad idris might was suggesting
before this might create
a concern for the future of democracy
well rob people here in chad were very
concerned about the political
developments
uh during this election period there
were people who supported president
debbie and therefore having his son
replace him in a military council in
place
with the now deceased president being a
military leader himself
uh they would accept that it's highly
unlikely that there will be resistance
from them
the opposition were against him um even
before the elections many of them
boycotted most prominent opposition
leaders
boycotted the elections uh others
withdrew uh they said that because
the the democracy process was not fair
and that the country had no democracy
and they've been calling for an
inclusive national dialogue to try to
steer the country
towards a transition towards democracy
then you have the armed groups who were
resisting
uh president debbie and his military uh
in the north which is
where he sustained those battles over
the weekend which eventually led to his
death
uh as announced by the military this
morning so the country is pretty much
divided between
the opposition who uh did not want deb
in power therefore will not welcome his
son and the military institution
uh in in the form of the military
council which has taken over right now
and you have the debbie supporters and
his ruling party supporters who will
highly likely accept the fact that his
son is now in place
then you have the rebels up in the north
we should note however
that constitutionally that is not the
case there should not be a military
council
constitutionally the speaker of the
parliament should be the one
leading for a period of 40 days uh
before a transitional government is put
in place
now the first thing the military did
after announcing that president debbie
has died because of the wounds he
sustained over the weekend
is announcing the dissolution of that uh
legislative assembly so
there is no speaker and that speaker
would not be able to leak for a period
of 40 days as stated by the constitution
so we have to wait and see the reactions
from the people
where they will accept the fact that the
military is now in charge
and that the constitution has been uh
put aside for for the time being
although we will see resistance uh in
the streets also worth noting that
prior to the elections there were people
who were protesting um
debbie's re-election they're saying that
they did not that's because of the
changes he made in the constitution
starting from 2005 which first of all
allowed him to run
um numerously and also gave him uh or
expanded his presidential power so the
constitution has been
played around quite a bit when president
debbie was in power where the people now
will want
the military uh council that has been
formed to abide by that
and hand over power to a civilian or to
attract to a speaker of the legislation
and bring back that legislative assembly
or not we'll have to wait and see uh how
this unfolds in the coming hours and
days
here but thanks very much hibber morgan
talking to us from chad's capital in
german
about that breaking news out of chad
where the army has been announcing that
president idris debbie has been killed
while leading soldiers on the front
lines to debbie just won re-election
and was one of africa's longest serving
leaders